i was going to talk about something
called a king model
and in particular this paper the
structure of star clusters three so it's
one of a series some simple dynamical
models by a guy called ivan king and the
reason why i was put in mind of this is
that sadly ivan just died very recently
the ripe old age of 94 so i had a good
innings this reminded me about this
paper and it was actually one of the
first papers i read when i was a phd
student
so it was uh because it was published in
1966 i wasn't a phd student quite that
long ago
but it's been a classic of the of the
field i checked uh the other day this
paper has been cited by other papers so
mentioned in other papers about two and
a half thousand times now so it's quite
a classic paper that's uh so for people
who don't know that's a lot of citations
yeah i mean you know
yes it's there are papers with more
citations than this but actually that's
right out there and i guess you know
citations are a slightly strange measure
in that this paper was written in 1966
so it's been around a long time to
collect citations but it's still
collecting citations now so it's clearly
a a classic of the honor ivan king
fascinating guy but the thing he's
probably best known for is studying
globular clusters spherical clusters of
stars quite old one nice thing about
them is that they're relatively simple
looking which means that there's some
hope that we can actually understand
them because they look nice and simple
and so what he was trying to do in these
models was trying to understand why they
have the appearance they do based on the
motions of the stars within them
although we see this kind of snapshot of
where the stars are now they're all
moving around if they weren't moving
around the whole thing will just
collapse under gravity so it's this kind
of the motions is what holds them up for
the fact that all the stars are orbiting
around like a swarm of bees
and he was really interested in looking
at what those motions should be in order
to understand the properties of the star
cluster if you looked at one little bit
of one of these star clusters the
simplest distribution that you could
have um for the motions of the stars if
you were just guessing because you don't
know
is you guessed that they were a gaussian
right that's what the bell curve right
let me draw one for you where we've got
the number of stars and how fast they're
moving but you get the general idea this
is zero in the middle here yeah and then
this is kind of big positive speeds and
this is big negative speeds so in fact
the largest number of stars aren't
moving in any given direction aren't
moving very fast now of course this is
i've only drawn in one direction in the
other directions they might be moving
around a bit faster because how can you
have negative speed but you mean yeah
yeah even though yes they're velocities
if you want to be technical about it
right some of them are moving to the
right some of them are moving to the
left so the most common thing is that
they're actually in if you look in any
particular direction they're actually
not moving very much but there's some
things moving very far something's
moving much slower why
gaussians come up everywhere in physics
right there's something about them that
just makes them come up all the time it
comes up all the time if you're doing
thermodynamics it's a very common
distribution it's a thing called the
maxwell boltzmann distribution that
comes up in gases and so on so as i say
the molecules in this room have a
distribution of speeds which are more or
less like that
and so you know you might naively think
well maybe that's how a cluster of stars
would behave as well because you know a
molecule moving around in a room is kind
of a bit like a star moving around in
the cluster it turns out that's not
quite true for a wide variety of reasons
one is that the part of the reason why
the molecules in the in
the gas in this room all end up with
this particular property is because they
keep bumping into each other and
rearranging their energy until they end
up in this particular configuration now
stars don't bump into each other
it's very rare for two stars to collide
mostly even in a tightly packed globular
cluster it's mostly empty space so it's
very rare for stars to actually collide
with one another and actually the forces
between stars are very different and the
forces between molecules only really
happen when they get very close together
and bump into each other gravity the
force between stars is a long-range
force
so there are you know
it's not obvious that you'd end up with
this this particular distribution but
it's a good place to start right in that
you know it's as i say it comes up so
often in physics it's what your first
guess would be
now it has certain
problems with it in that if we were to
think about let me just draw a cluster
of stars
so
okay and i'm going to pick one little
bit of this cluster not quite at the
edge but let's look at this just this
little bit in here and supposing that
all the stars in that little bit of the
cluster had a distribution like this
gaussian distribution one of the
problems with that is if you think about
well what's a star here going to do it
can go closer to the middle it can go
further away supposing we're looking at
the speeds in this radial direction some
things will be falling in some things
will be hanging out but the thing about
a gaussian is it just keeps going
forever
when it has these tails
so that means that some of the stars are
going to have very high velocities so
some of the stars here are going to be
moving out at very high speed and
they're just going to escape entirely or
at least they're going to travel off to
very large distances and because we've
got this gaussian distribution
everywhere we assume it's the same
gaseous distribution everywhere that
means that some of the stars are just
going to be able to travel out to
extremely large distances and that's not
necessarily a problem because actually
some systems are very big and maybe this
system just goes on and on to a very
large distance so what i've just drawn
here is a thing called an isothermal
sphere so it's a sphere because it's
round it's isothermal
but again by analogy with a gas right
the thermal isothermal means it all has
the same temperature in that case that
just means that this distribution of
velocities is the same everywhere
and so you end up with the this kind of
gaussian distribution of velocities
so you can do calculations to actually
calculate what what an isothermal sphere
would look like right a sphere of stars
where the only properties we've dictated
are it's held together by its own
gravity and the stars are moving around
with this gaussian distribution of
speeds and it's a fairly tedious but
doable calculation to actually figure
out what configurations you can end up
with once you end up with those two
properties and the answer is there are
perfectly good equilibrium situations
you can actually you can have a cluster
of stars like that
the slight snag with it is that for the
reasons i just been talking about it
extends out to infinity which is a bit
different from what you expect real real
clusters to do and actually even worse
than that
if you add up the stars all the way out
to infinity you end up with an infinite
mass
and we know clusters of stars don't have
infinite mass you know you can kind of
convince yourself well maybe they extend
to quite large distances but they
certainly don't have infinite mass and
in fact if you actually look at a
globular cluster one of these clusters
of stars that ivan was trying to model
they have a pretty sharp cutoff they
don't actually extend on and on they go
out for a certain distance and then they
stop
and that's probably to do with their the
fact that they're orbiting around the
milky way and if a star ventures too far
out the pull of gravity of the milky way
gets stronger than the polar gravity of
the cluster and it just gets whipped
away and so that's the limit that you
get from that is a thing called the
tidal radius effectually because it's a
kind of a tidal force which is just rips
the stars away if they venture too far
away it's got its own sphere of
influence it does yeah and then it stops
right the global cluster can do its
thing to a certain distance but then it
loses and actually stars just
disappeared from there and so what you
would really want is a model that kind
of is a bit like this has a distribution
which is a bit like a gaussian at the
the speeds
but actually stops at a very sharp
radius if we go back to our picture here
that means that basically the more
energetically the stars in here are
moving the further away they can get
they can get further and further and
further away if they're moving at higher
and higher speeds and they get slowed
down you know it's like throwing a ball
up in the air the harder you throw it
the higher it goes and then it comes
back down again
and it's the same here the star that's
traveling fastest will get further
before it gets turned around if there's
some sharp cutoff that tells you there
has to be some maximum speed here
because anything going faster than that
would actually get further away and so
the simplest picture you could come up
with
for making that happen
is actually to say okay so i'm not going
to allow the tails of this gaussian
distribution to go up forever i'm going
to cut them off so i'm going to throw
out all the stars from over here and
actually all the stars from the negative
side as well because i don't want it
coming out the other side of the cluster
either
and so you end up kind of cutting off
bits of the distribution and clearly as
you think about it if you go further and
further out
that maximum speed has to get lower and
lower right because right in the middle
here you can be traveling at a fair old
speed and you're still not going to get
beyond the tidal radius if you're out
here you can't go much further out
before you hit this tidal radius and so
the amount you cut off depends on how
far you are out there so we've end up
with the distribution that looks like
this of the remaining stars
now physically that's really ugly
because it has these incredibly sharp
cutoffs and so that means that there are
quite a lot of stars moving at this
speed and no stars at all moving at this
point and that's kind of a little bit
uncomfortable what ivan king's model did
you say okay well instead of just
throwing out low stars let's throw out
all of these stars as well
and so all you end up with is kind of
the top
of the gaussian distribution
and what happens is as you go further
and further away from the center here
you sort of move this line up
so you end up with less and less of the
distribution left behind that was
instead of assuming the thing was
gaussian everywhere so you end up with
this isothermal sphere what king came up
with is this thing called truncated
isothermal sphere which just basically
says okay we'll just throw out all the
stuff from below this line and then
we'll move that line up as we go in the
cluster and you can go through exactly
the same calculation that they went
through for the isothermal sphere to
figure out what that what that means in
terms of the structure that you end up
with and the answer is that you end up
with something which is a sphere it has
kind of a core radius so it's sort of
flattish in the middle then it goes down
a bit and then it cuts off very sharply
at the edges so here are the king models
it's a whole family of them again you
can mess around with exactly how quickly
it cuts off where the tidal radius is
and those kinds of things so you end up
with different a range of models here
but then he actually ends up trying to
fit them to some globular clusters so
the dots here are star counts from a
real cluster of stars and the line here
is one of these king models and he was
able to show that actually these king
models fit
the data from globular clusters
extremely well i assume he didn't call
them king models ah no probably not that
he's just been called king models ever
since but yes he was probably not that
vain
mathematically the whole thing is very
elegant and it's just very nice that
with this sort of the simplest thing
that you can do you can end up
explaining the structure of globular
clusters now it's clearly an
oversimplification
in that for example
the gaussian i've talked about here the
the random motions are the same in every
direction right it can be moving in and
out side to side in a stellar system
there's no reason why that has to be the
case it could be that things are moving
much more in the radial direction than
they are in the tangential direction for
example this model doesn't have that
built into it and we know actually some
globular trusses we do end up with those
kind of radial orbits as well
so that's part of the story the other
thing is that we've assumed that all the
stars are the same and so that all of
them can be drawn from the single
distribution we know that in a real
cluster there are stars of different
masses there are more massive stars less
massive stars and again you might expect
them to end up with different velocity
distributions just because you know
they'll end up sharing energy around
between them so that some stars will end
up moving faster than others so it's
clearly a great simplification but
actually it's just very elegant that
with that very simple model you can
actually reproduce the properties of
these globular clusters extremely well
has it stood the test of time is it
still a useful tool or it's a very
useful i mean as i say the reality is
almost certainly more complicated and so
actually people can do much more
sophisticated things now but if you want
if i'm trying to model something and i
want a nice simple test case to start
with i'll often still start with the
king model because it's just a nice
simple test case where i kind of
understand the properties of it and so
that if i'm trying to you know
predict what some other property of a
cluster will be it's a nice place to
start because i kind of understand
what's going on with the model what
about dark energy
you'd have to be able to see it in order
to know what shape it makes right yeah
but maybe that's affecting all the
movement of these stars as well
in globular clusters and one of the nice
thing about globular flusters is that
they're almost entirely dominated by the
mass of the stars so you don't have to
worry about dark matter dark energy of
the nasty cosmological stuff is another
reason why i like them like because
they're nice simple systems where you
only have to worry about the stars
dr king was he was he a big deal was he
like was he famous because of this
i mean famous because of this and a lot
of other stuff as well he did loads of
things he worked on developing new
telescopes instrumentation for
telescopes he was one of the first
people who did photoelectric photometry
so using electronics to measure the
brightness of in this case clusters of
stars rather than photographic plates he
was involved in the early stages of
computing some of it i believe is still
classified but he did a whole bunch of
stuff for the us military but also
astronomical computing so he had a very
long and kind of broad career but
globular clusters clusters of stars and
these kind of models are the things he's
probably best known for did you know him
or work with him i only ever had one
conversation with him i didn't know him
particularly well for my phd i actually
did some work which was associated with
global clusters and when you completed
your phd you then apply for these things
called postdocs which are like you know
three year fixed term
uh research positions
and you apply for a bunch of them
because actually you know
there's so people competing for them and
so you know you have to apply for loads
in the expectation of getting maybe one
or two offers um he offered me a job so
i applied for a postdoc with him to work
on hubble space telescope images of
globular clusters hubble space telescope
hadn't been launched at that point just
before the hst was launched and so it's
quite a cool kind of job i mean i would
get this hubble space telescope images
globular clusters and actually do some
analysis kind of along these lines and
he phoned me up so he phoned me up to
offer me the job and but he was clearly
quite embarrassed by the conversation
and it was because
he had some really strange there were
some strange rules associated with his
job which i think had been imposed by
his collaborators rather than him
and the rule was you i would be employed
to do these specific things with this
hubble space telescope data
if along the way while i was analyzing
that data i found anything else
i wouldn't be allowed to be an author on
any paper that came out of anything that
i sort of serendipitously discovered
along the line which is just a really
weird thing to do right you'd have
thought you know if somebody who's
working for you find something really
interesting in the data at the very
least there'd be an author on the paper
that described the interesting thing
they found but clearly this was some
rule they had in their collaboration
that actually people working on their
data were only working on the thing that
they were allowed to work on and
anything else they weren't allowed to be
involved with
um so he clearly he's phoned me up to
tell me this kind of expecting me when i
learned that to turn down the job which
i eventually did so i went somewhere
else instead
which is a shame because it had been a
great person to work with although
having said that of course then hubble
space telescope was launched and it
didn't work so actually i'd have spent a
lot of time trying to figure out how to
do things with the really dodgy images
that came out of hst when it was first
launched
if you'd like to learn a lot more about
globular clusters why not check out our
astronomy channel deep sky videos we've
been making films about all the objects
in the messier catalogue including but
not limited to
these globular clusters you're seeing on
screen at the moment there'll be a link
on screen and down in the video
description that's deep sky videos